Без бензину і дизелю. У міністерства інфраструктури грандіозні плани.
До 2030 року міський громадський транспорт в Україні має стати електричним
на 75 відсотків. Про це йдеться у Національній транспортній стратегії.
Наскільки реалістичні такі наміри в українських реаліях?
Електричний громадський транспорт є у 35 містах України.
Його основа - трамваї й тролейбуси. Метрополітен є лише у Києві, Харкові та
Дніпрі. Загалом в Україні - понад 2250 трамваїв та майже 3000 тролейбусів.
Їхня частка в міських пасажирських перевезенннях уже нині становить
близько 60 відсотків. Тобто задекларована міністерством інфраструктури мета
у 75 відсотків, здавалося б, не така вже й далека.
Щоправда, зношеність цих трамваїв та тролейбусів нині становить 60, а іноді й 85 відсотків.
А грошей на оновлення міських електропарків немає.
Щодо електробусів - вони якщо і з’являються в українських містах,
то лише як поодинокі експерименти. Приміром, у Києві з кінця 2018-го курсує
китайський електробус. На одній зарядці він може проїхати до 300 кілометрів.
Подібні електробуси також тестувалися у Вінниці, Житомирі та інших містах.
У Львові на заводі "Електрон" збирають електробуси українського виробництва - Е19.
Вони вдвічі дорожчі за дизельні автобуси, але в експлуатації
щонайменше вдесятеро дешевші, запевняє сам виробник,
тож різниця у вартості має компенсуватися вже за 5 років.
Однак українськими дорогами електробуси українського виробництва поки так і не їздять -
за контрактами їх поставляють до Колумбії, Єгипту та інших країн.
У Луцьку теж розробили ще у 2014 році електробус на базі "Богдана"
і він кілька років використовувався в рамках експерименту.
А в Одесі у 2019-му переробили старий чеський тролейбус на електробус.
Тож, ставку саме на електробуси в Україні, схоже, поки ніхто не робить.
Це пояснюють насамперед тим, що для цього потрібні значні інвестиції
в інфраструктуру - насамперед у зарядні станції.
Крім того, для масштабного введення в експлуатацію електробусів
потрібна розгалужена обслуговуюча інфраструктура з відповідним сервісом.
Рентабельність пасажирського транспорту на електриці на 15-20 відсотків
вища за транспорт з двигуном внутрішнього згорання.
Найвигідніша альтернатива автобусам на бензині чи дизелі - це тролейбуси.
Для мерій міст вони на 30-40 відсотків дешевші за електробуси -
за умови, що вже є тролейбусна інфраструктура.
Якщо ж є її немає, то містам в перспективі вигідніше робити ставку на електробуси.
Експерти радять, що варто одразу закуповувати електробуси з великим
об’ємом акумулятора, які можуть долати більшу відстань без підзарядки.
Електробуси з маленьким об’ємом акумулятора коштують дешевше,
але для них необхідно забезпечити можливість підзаряджатися на зупинках.
Натомість електробус з великим об’ємом акумулятора може проїхати
цілий маршрут і заряджатися лише на кінцевій зупинці.
Перехід на електротранспорт в Україні ускладнюється й тим, що центральна влада
в питаннях транспорту не може втручатися у справи міст.
Тож, часто немає належної координації між органами місцевого самоврядування  та мінінфраструктури.
Приміром, Київ замість нових електробусів торік придбав на умовах лізингу
200 дизельних автобусів виробництва Мінського автомобільного заводу.
Експерти розглядають це лише як тимчасове рішення:
поки столична інфраструктура для електротранспорту ще не створена, а значна частина тих автобусів,
що нині їздять київськими вулицями, потребують нагальної заміни.
Тобто влада у містах погоджується, що електробуси - це в перспективі вигідно,
але фінансові ресурси місцевих бюджетів обмежені.
Мерам потрібно терміново замінювати старі автобуси, тролейбуси і трамваї
та немає часу і грошей на розбудову інфраструктури для електричного транспорту.
Зробити громадський транспорт в Україні до 2030 року
на 75 відсотків електричним - реально лише за умови належного фінансування, вважають експерти.
Для початкових інвестицій у модернізацію та розбудову громадського електротранспорту
потрібні мільярди гривень. Зважаючи на пандемію та інші економічні проблеми,
у бюджеті на таку реформу явно бракує коштів.
За словами експертів, потрібна державна програма закупівлі електротранспорту,
який би потім віддавали громадам у лізинг або відтерміновували виплати.
Крім того, сподівання значною мірою на допомогу міжнародних партнерів.
Приміром, готується друга фаза проєкту Європейського інвестиційного банку
про міський громадський транспорт в Україні на 200 мільйонів євро.
Попередньо визначено 18 міст-учасників.
Саме другий етап цього проєкту має дати поштовх
появі електробусів на вулицях українських міст,
адже за цим кредитом містам буде дозволено купувати
транспорт лише з нульовими викидами в атмосферу.